bonjour à tous bienvenue dans Europe
hebbdo votre rendez-vous de l'actualité
européenne à moins d'un mois maintenant
du scrutin nous avons décidé de nous
mettre à l'heure de la campagne entouré
de journalistes étrangers et de
politologue nous allons décrypter ses
enjeux dans cette émission focus sur la
Grande-Bretagne un discours
anti-immigration des Rolant populistes
et largement anti-européen depuis
quelques mois Nigel farrage député
européen et leader du parti yukip et
l'OM qui monte sur la scène politique il
veut faire de son parti la première
force d'Angleterre et bouscule les
formations traditionnelles un scénario
qui n'est pas sans rappeler celui de
Marine Le Pen en France ou de gerzver au
Pays-Bas mais d'abord l'actualité David
Cameron esquisse les contours de son
Europe Herman von rumpeu fait son bilan
et les provocations de syvio Berlusconi
Simon Barbar pose la question de la
semaine l'Europe est-elle le bouc
émissaire
idéal c'est la faute à l'Europe à
quelques semaines du scrutin certains
partis conservateurs ont trouver leurs
arguments de campagne pour rassurer
leurs électeurs le Premier ministre
britannique David Cameron a donné le ton
dans la presse il réaffirme sa volonté
de proposer un référendum de sortie de
l'Union avant la fin de l'année 2017 et
puis tant qu'à faire son pays ne
participera jamais à l'euro ne fera
jamais partie de l'espace Schengen
rejette l'autorité de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme et est contre le
projet de défense européenne bref David
Cameron est européen mais il se soigne
et surprise Jean-Claude Junker le
candidat conservateur à la présidence de
la Commission se dit prêt à discuter des
spécificité
britannique de son côté le présid
président du Conseil européen Herman V
rompoy a la conscience tranquille le
désenchantement à l'égard des instances
européennes n'est pas lié à la gestion
de la crise financière et de toute façon
il l'affirme Bruxelles ça n'existe pas
l'Europe c'est la somme des décisions
collectives des
États-membres pas mal ça pour motiver
les électeurs mais il y a mieux Sylvio
Berlusconi s'est attaqué à Martin schuls
le candidat socialiste de la présidence
de la commission l'excavalieré explique
que pour les Allemands les camps de
concentration n'ont jamais
existé mais il est où le rapport et
pendant ce temps en France le parti
Europe Écologie les vers déplore une
campagne européenne trop courte pour
vanter l'Europe positive c'est sûr que
là on ne va pas leur donner tort alors
l'Union européenne un bou émissaire
idéal et pour évoquer cette épineuse
question l'Europe bouémissaire idéal
j'ai trois invités avec moi bonjour
Amandine Crespy vous êtes chercheuse
spécialiste des questions européennes et
professeur à l'ULB l'université l de
Bruxelles bonjour merci d'être avec nous
bonjour Simon Taylor vous êtes rédacteur
en chef adjoint de european Voice qui
est un journal qu'on connaît bien et
Lorenzo Consoli vous êtes journaliste
italien et correspondant pour le TM news
quand on voit un petit peu cette
actualité qui est un petit peu chargée
qu'est-ce que vous ressentez est-ce
qu'on doit dire aujourd'hui que l'Europe
est toujours le bouquéissaire des pays
des États et des politiques Simon euh
oui je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
problèmes qui sont attribués à l'Europe
quand on voit la campagne en
britannique en Angleterre pour pour pour
l'instant c'est beaucoup basé sur
l'immigration avec évidment on rendra
plus tard oui ok euh oui il y a beaucoup
qui sont atribu à l'Europe oui c'est
vrai alors ce syndrome c'est la faute à
Bruxelles comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquez
Lorenzo moi je dois dire que c'est c'est
cette fois-ci euh il est vrai que c'est
la fate à Bruxelles de la crise cette
crise- là la crise qui a commencé en
Europe en 2010 pas la crise qui a
commencé aux États-Unis d'Amérique en
2008 mais la crise qui a commencé en
Europe en 2010 c'est c'est la faute à
Bruxelles ce sont les décisions qui ont
été prises complètement mauvaises au
niveau de la gestion de la de la zone
euro qui ont créé une crise ils ont
infligé une crise à l'Europe qui n'était
pas nécessaire ce sont des mauvais choix
c'est la faute de l'Europe oui
absolument il faut aussi dire que c'est
la crise la pire que l'Union européenne
n jamais connu euh depuis la fondation
même de la de la de la Communauté
européenne et et euh à mon avis je suis
là depuis très longtemps euh la la
responsabilité est là est claire et C
ces élections sont différents de tous
les autres élections qu'on qu'on a vu
jusqu'à présent parce que pour la
première fois on peut vraiment dire euh
qui a été responsable de cette crise les
gens qui sont au pouvoir en Europe donc
quand Herman V rompo dit par exemple que
ce désenchantement vis-à-vis de l'Europe
n'est pas lié à l'action des des
gouvernements respectifs et et de
Bruxelles en gros il manque enfin il est
il ni la réalité il ni la réalité il dit
une chose qui euh est absolument le
contraire de ce qui est sous les yeux de
tout le monde c'est-à-dire que c'est
effectivement ce sont les choix de
Bruxelles qui ont créé euh une situation
euh très très difficile pour beaucoup de
gens dans surtout dans le Sud de
l'Europe et euh alimenter la la montée
des populismes la montée des des des
situations la Moné des mouvements contre
l'Europe et et on est dans une situation
aujourd'hui dans laquelle il faut même
peut-être se poser la question s'il ne
faut pas revoir l'euro pour sauver
l'Europe h c'est peut-être ça la
l'alternative de laquelle il faudra
discuter pendant ces élections et
surtout après Amandine Crespi comment
est-ce qu'on explique le président du
Conseil et à forceorie la plupart des
des instances européennes et de leurs
représentants sont aveuglés à ce point
sur les raisons du désenchantement
vis-à-vis de l'Europe je sais pas s'ils
sont aveuglés je pense qu'il y a une
conscience des problèmes mais c'est vrai
que un certain nombre de questions on a
l'impression sont un petit peu tabou et
on peut être d'accord ou pas avec les
conceptions britannique mais en lançant
le débat et en revendiquant
l'organisation d'un référendum dans son
pays David Cameron a le mérite de mettre
les pieds dans le plat et de pointer du
doigt un certain nombre de problèmes qui
sont des problèmes de fond et c'est vrai
que un certain nombre de responsables
institutionnels ou même de de leaders
nationaux on a l'impression ne veulent
pas aujourd'hui parler de ces questions
fondamentales qui sont est-ce que
l'Europe doit être plus qu'un grand
marché les Britanniques ont leur avis
sur la question est-ce qu'il fallait
s'engager dans la monnaie unique avec
toutes les obligations et
l'interdépendance que cela a créé donc
maintenant c'est une question à laquelle
évidemment les membres les pays membres
de la zone euro doivent faire face
est-ce que le modèle de développement
économique à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne ça doit être la mobilité des
travailleurs saant que la mobilité des
travailleurs ça renvoie aussi à une
concurrence intraeuropéenne c'estàdire
que globalement on l'a vu avec le débat
sur la directive sur le détachement des
travailleurs un rouain coûtera de toute
façon moins cher qu'un Anglais à
forceori moins cher qu'un Français et ça
crée des disparités si je puis dire dans
les dans les pays d'accueil quoi voilà
c'est la question du modèle de
développement économique basé sur la
concurrence où chaque pays va exploiter
et c'est bien normal ses points forts
donc ça explique aussi ça concerne la
mobilité des travailleurs mais ça
concerne aussi par exemple les questions
de politiqu Industri
la question de savoir si on peut avoir
des industries automobiles fortes dans
chaque pays des agricultures fortes dans
chaque pays et cetera et cetera alors le
problème c'est que la campagne n'a pas
véritablement démarré ou du moins à
peine où en est l'état de la campagne
Simon en Angleterre en ce moment est-ce
que ces débat intéresse un petit peu les
Anglais
euh oui mais on peut pas dire que c'est
suivi dans les grands médias en fait ce
qu'on suit c'est c'est l'affaire c'est
les les sondages pour UKIP le UK
nous aussi allons parler dans quelques
minutes oui ce qui est très important
mais je je dois dans les médiia grand
public il n'y a pas beaucoup de de de
rapportag sur sur les élections
européennes sauf sur ukp qu'est-ce qui
se passe avec Nadel Farage
Lorenzo on a vu syvio Berlusconi encore
faire de la provocation dans ce dans ce
petit sujet qu'est-ce qu'il pèse encore
en Italie euh de moins en moins en fait
dans cette même émission dans laquelle
il a dit euh ses fouaises euh on a on a
pour la première fois je crois on a euh
enregistré une baisse de de la de
l'écoute de l'audimat alors que alors
qu'il parlait et donc oui donc en fait
il il a il commence à fatiguer un peu
les gens avec
seses affirmations ces provocations et
cetera euh par contre une chose qu'il
faut dire c'est cette phrase sur les
Allemands euh moi je ne crois pas les
Allemands qui si on demande aux
Allemandes il ils ne savent pas qu'il y
a qu'il y a eu les les les les champ de
concentration en Asie
euh je je ne crois pas qu'il qu'il a dit
ça comme ça parce que parfois il il dit
des choses sans sans penser sans trop
penser mais là il voulait intercepter
vraiment le sentiment antialéand qui est
très fort aujourd'hui dans les pays du
sud de la zone euro et en Italie aussi
parce que on voit que la la on considère
que la crise a été crée la crise de la
zone euro a été créée par les mauvaises
choix de de Bruxelles et deunion
européenne mais sous euh vraiment la la
l'emprise de de de l'égémonie l'égémonie
de du gouvernement allemand de Merkel et
schoble et ça c'est quelque chose qui
est très très répondu dans tous les pays
du Sud et c'est une autre question euh
qui n'existait pas avant c'est-à-dire
pour la première fois on revoit en
Europe des divisions nationales des des
une animosité une une forte euh critique
des des des autres pays de d'un pays
comme l'Allemagne en plus qui est
considéré comme un mauvais pays hégémon
il il ne mérite pas l'hégémonie qu'il a
au niveau de la zone euro parce queil ne
pense que à ses intérêts nationaux
contre les intérêts généraux de l'Europe
un pays peu solidaire alors depuis
quelques mois David Cameron est talonné
sur sa droite par Nigel Farage le
fantasque leader du UKIP le parti
eurosceptique et anti-immigré nous avons
donc voulu savoir comment ça se passait
sur place reportage à Londres de
Faustine
saint-genéès bienvenue à barking dans la
banlieue est de Londres ce quartier des
hérités est le point de chute de
nombreux immigrés notamment les nouveaux
arrivants en provenance d'Europe de
l'Est lituanien hongrois roumain
ou encore bulg à tel point que désormais
un habitant sur de dans ce quartier est
étranger un sujet visiblement
sensible l'immigration est devenu un
thème important qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous trouvez qu'on en parle
trop j'ai pas mal de choses à faire il
faut vraiment que j'y aille
désolé les noir rest avec les Noirs les
asiatiques avec les asiatiques vous
voyez quoi avant nétait pas comme ça les
gens se mélangeai c'est devenu vraiment
dur vous
savez il y a beaucoup d'étrangers qui
viennent s'installer ici du coup nous
sommes devenu une
minorité ils sont plus nombreux c'est
eux la majorité
aujourd'hui si les autorités peuvent
réguler l'immigration internationale
avec l'espace Schengen elles n'ont plus
la maîtrise des flux
intraeuropéens ce thème de l'immigration
européenne a fait irruption ces derniers
mois dans le débat public au Royaume-Uni
pays du uralisme et si le sujet prend
une telle ampleur après avoir été tabou
pendant des années c'est à cause de la
percée électorale de
l' ce parti eurosceptique et
antiimmigration qui doit beaucoup à son
leader le charismatique Nigel Farage
nous devons contrôler l'immigration nous
devons choisir les gens nous l'avions
rencontré en octobre
dernier nous devons avoir une politique
d'immigration qui réponde à besoins qui
n pas de cas judiciaire pas de maladie
grave mais des compétences à apporter un
homme politique atypique dans le paysage
anglais qui séduit en masse l'électorat
populaire c'est un homme politique
extraordinaire Farage il a une vraie
touche de de de populiste il est il est
il
parle il parle une langue simple il
parle une langue directe c'est par peur
de Farage que ils ont été obligés que
les autres parties ont été obligés de
commencer à parler de l'immigration
c'est parce que Farage piquait des votes
surtout du Parti
conservateur sous la pression de l'UKIP
le gouvernement a pris des mesures pour
restreindre l'immigration européenne
notamment d'Europe de l'Est en limitant
par exemple l'accès aux indemnités de
chômage ou à l'allocation logement les
conséquences pourraient être dramatiques
dans certains secteurs comme le bâtiment
ou cette main d'
néaire c'est un procédé typique de l'a
droite réactionnaire de mettre tout sur
le dos des immigrés plutôt que de
regarder l'ensemble du pays et ce qu'ils
ont pu nous apporter si nous enlevons la
main d'œuvre européenne des chantiers il
faudrait tout simplement les fermer et
cela aurait un impact sur le secteur
Antier à long terme y compris sur les
salariés
britanesus University College of London
démontre l'impact positif de
l'immigration européenne sur l'économie
britannique un message qui a pourtant du
mal à passer dans l'opinion publique
certains mythes ont la vie dure comme
celui des benefit tourist traduction les
touristes aux
allocations Barbara est responsable
d'une ONG qui vient en aide aux migrants
d'Europe de l'Est arrivé de Pologne en
2008 elle a été confrontée à certains
préjugés on m'a posé la question est-ce
que tu viens ici pour voler des emplois
j'ai répondu mais quel genre de travail
je viendrais voler je sais pas femme de
ménage comme si j'étais une femme de
ménage professionnel pourquoi j'iraai
volé un travail de femme de ménage et
peu à peu on finit par en rire mais au
début il faut faire avec ces a priori
désormais Barbara se sent intégrée à
Londres mais elle redoute que le climat
ne s'en venime avec les élections
européennes des élections où l'ukipe de
Nigel farrage pourrait devenir la
première force politique du
pays Simon le yukip première force
politique du pays vous y croyez non
seulement dans le sens que dans les
élections pour les pour le Parlement
européen ils vont peut-être être le le
le parti le le plus soutenu le le
dernier sondage indique un taux des de
de 31 % c'est c'est ils ont dépassé les
les travaillistes pour la première fois
mais mais ce qu'il faut mais ça veut pas
dire que c'est une force politique dans
dans tout le pays IP a pour l'instant
aucun député dans le dans le House of
Commons et aujourd'hui najo Farage a
pris la décision de ne pas se présenter
pour une siège dans le House of Commons
parce qu'il y a un député conservateur
qui s'est démissionné donc c'est
uniquement sur l'Europe et dans le dans
le Parlement européen qui euh qu'ils ont
qu's ont une influence et et pour moi ça
indique euh la faiblesse euh la
faiblesse relative du Parlement européen
parce que les électeurs peuvent dire euh
euh je suis prêt à soutenir ukup parce
que je sais ça change rien sur la
fiscalité ça change rien sur
l'enseignement ça change rien sur les
les soins de santé euh et en tant que le
vote dans le Parlement européen on a
l'impression que ça changeement gros
beaucoup dans les grands sujet euh
croissance euh euh emploi euh les
électeurs vont être prêts à à encore
fait des des des des votes de proteste
et pour moi UKIP c'est un vote de
proteste surtout contre les les partis
établis parce que tous les partis en
pouvoir euh soit conservateur soit
social-démocrate on ont dû imposer une
sorte d'austérité ils ont dû euh
redresser les les les les les les
finances publiques et c'est pour ça dans
une atmosphère de de de faible
croissance économique de de de Ch taux
de chômage élevé euh que les électeurs
euh sont tentés par des
en gros ce sera un vote de crise c'est
ça vous êtes d'accord Amandine Crespi
c'est un vote de crise ce recours comme
ça c'est c'est pas uniquement en
Angleterre on a la même chose enance on
a la même chose en France avec le pront
national on a le Pays-Bas gver on a la
Ligue du Nord en Italie on a l'au doré
en Grèce ENF c'est malheureusement la
liste s'allonge oui bon les partis
populistes extrémistes évidemment
profitent toujours des crises et il font
le leur commerce électoral en période de
crise pourquoi parce qu'ils pointent du
doigt les vrais problèmes euh semble y
apporter des réponses de bon sens donc
il parle un langage de facilité de c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que na Joh Farage
les appelle ce sont des réponses de bon
sens à des problématiques voilà le bon
sens sur des problèmes compliqués et
malheureusement les parties en place de
gouvernement n'apporte bien souvent pas
beaucoup de réponse et même pas beaucoup
de discours sur ces questionsl on va y
revenir sur l'immigration par
exemple il y a une attitude parfois qui
consiste à nier les réalités ce qui est
contre-productif on peut pas nier que le
Royaume-Uni a été
particulièrement concerné avec voilà
plus d'un million de personnes qui sont
arrivées ça change cétait un choix
politique hein c'était cétait fait
exprès tout à fait ça a été un choix en
2004 où le Royaume-Uni a choisi de ne
pas mettre de restriction à l'arrivée
donc au moment de l'élargissement à
l'Europe centrale et orientale et là de
nouveau il faut s'interroger pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce que l'immigration est
bénéfique pour l'économie parce que
c'est un réservoir de main d'œuvre peu
cher dans des secteurs l'Oreca la
construction où on manque de main
d'œuvre et donc là il faut s'interroger
aussi il y a pas une forme de dumping
aussi sur la main d'œuvre le fait
d'aller chercher cette immigration qui
est souvent moins bien payée
effectivement il y a un problème me de
dumping et de contournement des règles à
la fois nationales et surtout
européennes qui parfois ne sont pas
suffisamment efficaces mais de nouveau
le dumping est possible avant tout parce
que les États ne conduisent pas de
contrôle et les États ne font pas de
contrôle parce que la main d'œuvre bon
marché ça booste l'économie donc il faut
se poser les questions à tous les
niveaux alors il y a un autre débat qui
qui est celu celui-ci plus
institutionnel Lorenzo il est question
d'une alliance entre le fr national le
Parti de la liberté de gvilder aux
Pays-Bas peut-être la Ligue du Nord n
Joel Farage a refugé de participer à une
alliance avec Marine Le Pen euh
qu'est-ce quel est le risque pour le
Parlement européen de voir arriver un
groupe d'une centaine de de députés
europhobes ou anti-européens il faut
dire avant tout que ce n'est pas la
première fois que les les forces
anti-européennes essayent de former un
groupe soudé un groupe commun disons au
Parlement européen il faut dire aussi
que dans le Parlement européen si on
n'est pas dans un groupe si on est dans
les
on ne pèse rien il y a des groupes
euroceptiques mais un groupe de
populistes antiuropéen jamais aussi
parce que dans ce populisme antiuropéen
il y a beaucoup un élément de
nationalisme qui fait que c'est
difficile de mettre ensemble des
nationalismes différents pour ce qui
conc la Ligue du Nord le parti de
maradine Le Pen et les autres qui qui
ont essayé de de créer cette ce qui vont
essayer de créer ces groupes je crois
qu'ils ont qu'ils réussiront à le faire
mais ils ne vont pas voir euh chez eux
tous euh tous les partis populistes
parce que justement lukip ne veut pas
participer on sait pas ce qu'il va faire
après et il y a d'autres groupes qui ne
vont pas participer non plus peut-être
il il y aura quelques quelques élus qui
sera convaincu parce qu'il faut quand
même avoir SEP euh les les députés élus
de SEP pays au moins pour pouvoir former
un groupe au Parlement européen alors
quelqu'un qui à mon avis ne va surtout
pas participer à ce groupe là c'est
c'est Grillo bon son mouvement le
mouvement de Grillo qui est crédité
aujourd'hui de de 24 % de voix en Italie
pour les élections européennes c'est un
sondage d'hier et ce qui veut dire entre
qu'il aura entre 20 et 25 députés alors
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire Grillo Grillo
c'est un un populisme complètement
différent des autres à mon avis parce
qu'il y a beaucoup plus d'éléments de
gauche que d'éléments de de de droite il
est un peu un immigration mais pour le
reste il est fortement engagé surous les
questions environnementales et là à mon
avis il y a une alliance naturelle qui
se fera avec les avec les vers il est
pas fédéraliste ce que sont les Verts il
est pas fédéraliste comme les Verts mais
il faut dire aussi qu'il est proche des
positions de de six place pour qui
concern donc la gauche radical pour ce
qui concerne l'euro c'est-à-dire contre
l'euro en tant que tel tel qu'il a été
géré aujourd'hui mais pas contre
l'Europe Amandine Cresp est-ce qu'il a
véritablement un risque de blocage des
institutions européennes si la droite
populiste ou les droites nationalistes
on plusieurs noms arrive à constituer un
groupe non un blocage complet
certainement pas on se dirige donc comme
ça a été dit probablement vers deux
voire trois groupes de de droite
eurosceptique populistes groupes
différents euh donc ce qui est sûr c'est
que euh la proportion de ces forces
politiques là euh va augmenter de
manière assez considérable au sein du
Parlement européen euh et surtout euh et
je fais écho à ce qui vient d'être dit
sur les textes
particuliers même à l'intérieur d'un
même groupe si on avait un groupe
réunissant par exemple h Wilders le FPE
autrichien et Marine Le Pen il y a très
certainement un grand nombre de textes
sur lesquels ils auraient bien du mal à
se mettre d'accord notamment parce que
Marine Le Pen a joué sur la corde
sensible sociale française qui est à
l'opposé des conceptions libérales
d'autres populistes européens alors lors
du débat qui a été organisé par Euronews
il y a quelques jours les différents
représentants des partis politiques ont
tenu à formuler une réponse sur
l'extrême droite en Europe on les
écoute nous devons avoir un dialogue
avec les citoyens sur des solutions
concrètes ce que je veux faire c'est
montrer qu'ils n'ont pas de solution ils
n'ont que des bouques émissaires mais
non
T c défis auquel nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui ont besoin d'une solution
européenne nous devons nous attaquer au
cintes de la population nous devons
prendre au sérieux les cintes de la
population il faut faire la différence
entre qui critique en partie pour des
raisons justifié l'intégration
européenne et ceux qui sont contre
l'intégration européenne je ne débattrai
pas avecx ce ne sont pas des membres de
la famille avec lesquels je dois
dialoguer je suis Contrex
je pense que c'est vraiment dangereux
que les partis démocratiques ne doivent
en aucun cas prendre cette solution de
facilité qui est l'utilisation des
slogans de bas étage nous devrions
toujours être fort et ne pas avoir peur
de faire face à l'extrême
droite Simon est-ce qu'il a un manque de
réponse globale de la part des parties
classiques si je puis dire à l'extrême
droite on les sent un pe peu
désempar oui oui en fait c'est très
difficile parce que dans une période de
crise économique on a on a dû redresser
les euh euh les finances publiques il le
taux de chômage est très élevé euh et et
et et et donc les solutions très euh
populistes et faciles euh des des partis
d'extrême droite et antieuropéen sont
très euh sont très efficaces ce qui fait
vraiment c'est relancer la croissance en
Europe et euh ça c'est très difficile
c'est comme comme monsieur jean-claudien
a dit hier c'est pas lesom politiques
qui créent des emplois c'est les
entreprises donc il faut
créer une Europe compétitive qui doit
concurrencier maintenant avec l'Asie
avec avec le Brésil avec tous les autres
pays ça c'est ça c'est difficile à à
faire qu'est-ce que vous pensez Amandine
Crespy de de ces réponses des des partis
classiques si je puis
dire je crois
que il doit y avoir ou il va y avoir une
une évolution grationnel et j'ai
l'impression que parfois des
dirigeants peut-être de l'ancienne
génération comme Jean-Claude Junker ont
tendance à continuer à utiliser la
l'ancienne stratégie qui consiste à
stigmatiser les populistes en disant
qu'il ne font pas vraiment partie du
vrai jeu politique et cetera je crois
qu'on est arrivé véritablement au bout
de cette stratégie là et qu'il faut
maintenant une réponse à la fois sur les
questions particulières comme
l'immigration le chômage et à la fois
sur le projet d'ensemble de l'Europe ça
suffit plus de dire que les populistes
n'ont pas de réponse parce que en
prenant dans bien des cas le retour à
l'autonomie nationale éventuellement la
sortie de la zone euro et cetera ce sont
eux qui proposent les seules
alternatives aujourd'hui là où bien
souvent les citoyens en écoutant côte à
côte Martin Schulz Jean-Claude juner et
gu ferhofstad ne comprennent pas très
bien où se situent les ligne de conflit
fondamental et les projets différ
sachant qu'en plus en Europe on est
plutôt dans la culture du consens à 28
forcément donc tout ceci en fait crée
une forme de flou sur et et encore plus
s'il y a s'il y
a bon résultat pour les partis
populistes les les partis V vont faire
une grande coalition ensemble h h
Lorenzo vous allez avoir le dernier mot
est-ce que vous êtes confiant sur ces
prochaines élections je crois que on a
pour la première fois vraiment un des
élections européennes qui qui vont
déterminer la survie du projet
européenne h où son déclin et c'est la
première fois que ça arrive parce que
cette crise est une est une crise
vraiment euh grave gravissime et je ne
sais pas si les gens sont vraiment
conscients de ça mais euh j'espère que
le le débat dans la pour les élections
européennes arrive à focaliser ce point
euh ce sont des choix très importantes
soit on continue avec la même Europe
qu'on a connu jusqu'à présent et qui a
échoué qui a elle a échoué a échoué dans
ses institutions elle a échoué dans ses
choix de de politique économique
a elle a échoué dans sa distance par
rapport aux citoyens elle a pas réussi à
à comprendre le drame de certains citoy
de certains citoyens de d'un ensemble de
citoyens qui sont surtout dans les pays
du sud de l'Europe elle est devenu une
Europe des créditeurs c'est-à-dire ce
sont les créditeurs qui dictent la loi
économique discours de Martin Schul
c'est l'Europe des banques et pas
l'Europe des citoyens oui c'est c'est
l'Europe des crédit
héi lesat créditeur alors il faut sortir
de là il faut il faut avoir une Europe
qui soit vraiment l'Europe des citoyens
qui qui revient à faire les intérêts
généraux des citoyens et là c'est très
important qui sera le prochain président
de la Commission et les choix que la
Commission va faire bon écoutez merci à
tous les trois d'avoir participé avec
moi aujourd'hui à ce décryptage nous on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine sur les
chaînes parlementaires bonne suite de
programme
jean-l